Do what the fuck happened to the guy who did the subway things?
Jared says he finds middle school girls hot.
Some chick was taping them for fucking four years. He's caused a lot of pain.
It's pain that will never go away. Well for saying that. Yeah,
you must've gone a little further than that. On Wednesday,
Fogel admitted that he had sex with at least two minors and obtained child
pornography of 12 other children as young as six years old.
A boy. Dude, is anybody safe?
Can anybody go wire to wire without the fucking hammer coming down?
Jared Fogle is a monster. He's a monster. That's what she said.
How funny is it that I was just talking to you guys about eating right and
getting in shape and I go look at Google fucking news.
So I got some that run my Goddamn Yap about
Jesus Christ and he looks like Derosa.
That's fucking hilarious. You gotta be fucking kidding me.
Fogo served as subway spokesman for 15 years.
Ever since he first appeared on television claiming that eating the fast food
chains sandwiches and working out helped them lose more than 200 pounds. Place.
He probably lost that money running out the back door when the parents came.
See, this is dumb. I shouldn't be doing this. This guy has not been connected.
Did I have anything? Oh, but he's completely fucked. He better had done it.
I mean, I hope he didn't for kids' sake,
but I mean he's fucked now it's over.
What's he going to go over to? Blimpie [inaudible] hey everybody,
I'm wrongly accused. Accused a child molester.
Jared Fogle.
And I'm going to tell you that a Blimpie's makes you even more skinny.
And what the stress is sitting there, a [inaudible], you know,
thinking I was going to go to jail for that Shit and get gang raped because
that's what happened. God, Jared, Jared, what did you do?
Oh my God, if he, if he fucking did this shit and he's guilty, he goes to jail.
Do you have any fucking idea what's going on?
I love that they put them in protective custody for how fucking long.
You know what I mean? I figured maybe eight, 10 years. He's fucked.
Literally. Oh my God. They'll descend on it, mate. Jeremy,
do you want the six of the 12 inch? God,
I'm fucking kill myself.
Okay.
Oh, there's gotta be a way to do it. Pays to fucking skinny now to hang himself.
Just sit there twitching around like a fucking God damn fly.
They got its wing ripped off.
How do you kill yourself when you're shaped like a pencil? Oh God.
What do you do? Oh, I know I do. I'd fucking break my glasses and I jam.
One of the pieces in my neck just bleed out in the cell. Here you go.
They see there's a way.
You know that you put somebody in a confined area that they're going to come up
with something. You gotta be fucking kidding me.
I don't understand why before the guys convicted that his face is all over the
fucking place.
I don't get it because if this guy didn't do this shit, it was like,
what the fuck I was talking about last week about the hockey player there.
It's like if they didn't do it, they're completely fucked.
They're fucked either way.
Either they did it and they go into jail and they getting gang raped.
You know what? You know let's what you get for doing that shit.
But on the other side, if you didn't do whatever you,
you know what do, what are you doing? How do you make your money then?
Yeah,
I dunno. You gotta be fucking kidding me. Wow.
Okay.
Jeb Bush. Donald Trump on apologetic for anchor baby language. I gotta.
I gotta be honest with you as far as like, you know, offensive shit.
Anchor baby. That's good. It's pretty fucking light. You know what I mean?
There's no racial epitaphs there. There's nothing homophobic anchor baby.
It's the baby that gets you in here. You know, you put down roots, right?
I've about a root baby. A root. A baby.
Hate that fucking report there. Turn your, turn your face. Shut the fuck up.
You're offensive. You fucking can't.
You work for some corporate God Damn News News fucking paper.
Quit acting like you're giving out the facts. You jerk off,
you write about what they tell you to write about.
That's what you should have done.
You what they tell you right about then you go on your cash,
those checks down yet and you got to go buy yourself an Audi, right? Or a BMW,
some German sedan that lets the broads know you fucking,
you know you're on the dull. Um,
you gotta be fucking kidding me, man. Jesus Christ.
If you can't trust a form of fuck fat fuckers eating sandwiches to be around
your kids, honestly, who can you trust?
That would have been a great fucking segue to go into a my advertising with a
fuck. Is it? Oh, it's over here. That Jesus,
everything's just falling apart on me here. All right. I,
it's time for some advertising. I mean, what else?
What else do you do after you talk about the form of fat?
Fuck who became a skinny guy and then a allegedly
Jesus Christ. I get why anyways, I don't fuck you.
Think you're going to get away with something like that. Um, all right.
We want thing. If you were the spokesperson for Wendy's, like that old guy,
then he could just say, Nah, I was just dressed as Santa.